[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens dans l'attentât ses
longues transport pas totale pas tout à
fait propre
les conducteurs qui sont pas aimables
non plus pas agréable pour nos touristes
votre heure il en bon choix mon frère il
est pas de potes
quand j'ai vu que je vous reconnais pas
dans l'ensemble je suis assez content la
ligne est très c'est l'horreur on a
beaucoup j'ai pas utiliser vos marques
j'en sais rien par contre les noctiliens
c'est de la merde travail l'ambiance qua
non frère pendant mon frère il les
utilise pas demain que j'en sais rien
vous êtes son frère en bas c'est one
sait pas c'est que c'est pour ces huit
ans vous emmerdez du g8
c'est quoi ça n'a cette fois c'est baba
va chez le coiffeur on en fait un prime
qui est le meilleur baba qui ressemble à
baba c'est quoi les aventures de baba bâ
m'a fait du ski c'est quoi la 1re manche
de baba ce nom c'est ça non baba contre
la moussaka géante sais quoi encore que
ce célibat bâbord c'est marrant ça te
coûte à dire voter coûte pas trop on
soit soir maison qu'est ce que vous
pensez des transports en commun
parisiens
je les trouve plutôt très vif ragas j'en
suis très contente
il pourrait fonctionner plus tard la
nuit par exemple je me sens en sécurité
contrairement au rer la nuit en ile de
france où je me sens pas en sécurité
donc je le trouve super et qu'est ce que
je voulais dire d'autre voilà quoi
d'autre
allez rr moyens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]